This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There are symbols all around us that we take for granted. Like the lightning strike icon to indicate that something is high voltage, or a little campfire to indicate that something is flammable. Those icons, they might have some fascinating origin story, but their symbolism is pretty obvious. But other abstract icons are not so straightforward. Like why does one vertical line and two angled lines inside of a circle indicate peace?
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我们周围到处都是我们习以为常的符号。比如表示高压的闪电图标，或者表示易燃的小营火图标。这些图标可能有着迷人的起源故事，但它们的象征意义非常明显。但其他抽象图标就没那么直观了。比如，为什么圆圈里的一条竖线和两条斜线代表和平？
Where does the smiley face come from? Or the power button? Today, we've sent out the 99pi team to dig into the backstory behind some of those images you see every day. You might know what they mean, but you don't know why they mean what they mean. We're calling this episode ubiquitous icons. So Emmett is here to bring us the story of the piece symbol. Here I am. And we're not talking about the piece symbol like two fingers up when someone takes a picture.
笑脸符号是从哪里来的？电源按钮呢？今天，我们派出了99pi团队去挖掘你每天看到的那些图像背后的故事。你可能知道它们是什么意思，但你不知道它们为什么是这个意思。我们将这一集称为“无处不在的图标”。埃米特在这里为我们讲述和平符号的故事。我在这儿。我们说的不是那种拍照时比出两根手指的和平手势。
Right. No. The drawing of takes a picture. Right, no. The drawing of a circle with a little stick. Yeah, the one that looks kind of like the Mercedes-Benz logo that you see everywhere. I mean, it's kind of hard to think of a more ubiquitous icon than the P symbol. Yeah, right. It's truly, truly everywhere. And I think what interested me about it was that despite it's sort of total ubiquity, it has a very, very specific origin story. Oh, that's cool. Okay, so hit me with it.
对，不是。画一个圆圈，中间有一根小棍。对，就是那种看起来像你随处可见的梅赛德斯-奔驰标志的那个。我的意思是，很难想到比和平符号更无处不在的图标了。没错。它确实无处不在。我认为它吸引我的地方在于，尽管它完全普及，但它有一个非常非常具体的起源故事。哦，那太酷了。好吧，告诉我吧。
So the symbol goes back to the 1950s and a British organization called the direct action committee against nuclear war. That's a good name. It does what it says on the 10th. Yeah, yeah. That's pretty self-explanatory. They were an anti-nuclear group. It was the 1950s. It was the early days of the Cold War and nuclear proliferation. Britain itself was developing a hydrogen bomb. There was this growing activist sentiment that they didn't want the country to go down
这个符号可以追溯到20世纪50年代，一个名为“反核战争直接行动委员会”的英国组织。这名字起得好。名副其实。是的，是的。这很直观。他们是一个反核组织。那是20世纪50年代。那是冷战和核扩散的早期。英国本身正在研制氢弹。当时有一种日益增长的激进情绪，人们不希望国家走上那条道路。
that path. And so in 1958, they started organizing this really big march from London to a weapons facility in a town called Aldermastin, which was about 50 miles away. Oh, so this is like a long march, like a multi-day march. Right. One of the people who helped organize that march was a man named Gerald Holton. And Holton was an artist and a designer. He trained at the Royal College of Art. And it was his job to design all the posters and the banners and whatnot for the march. And he specifically wanted to design a symbol, something that could convey the goals
所以在1958年，他们开始组织一场从伦敦到奥尔德马斯顿镇武器设施的大规模游行，大约有50英里远。哦，所以这是一场长途游行，像多日游行一样。对。帮助组织那次游行的人之一是一位名叫杰拉尔德·霍尔顿的男士。霍尔顿是一位艺术家和设计师。他在皇家艺术学院受过培训。他的工作是为游行设计所有的海报、横幅等等。他特别想设计一个符号，一个能够传达这些游行者目标、传达这种反核扩散理念的符号。你知道，他想让它简单，易于复制，并且能做成很多标语牌。我猜他就是我们所知的和平符号的设计者。你说对了。那么这个具体的设计到底来自哪里？它应该代表什么？
of these marchers, convey this idea of anti nuclear proliferation. And you know, he wanted to be simple, something that could be reproduced, and a lot of signs. And I take it that he's the one who came up with the P sign as we know it. You got it. So where is the specific design actually come from? Like what is it supposed to represent?
嗯，要回答这个问题，我想我们需要绕个小弯。你熟悉旗语吗？是的，我的意思是，那是一种交流方式，你手里拿着两面旗子，用手臂摆出不同的姿势，象征不同的字母。完全正确，完全正确。
Well, to answer that, I think we need to take a small diversion. So are you familiar with semiforce? Yeah, I mean, it's the communication where you have two flags in your hands and you write different positions with your arms and it symbolize different letters. Exactly, exactly.
所以旗语，这个概念可以追溯到18世纪末的法国。一个叫克劳德·沙普的人发明了它，基本上它就像是一个塔楼网络，在这些塔楼顶部有某种木制结构，可以被操纵以创造出象征特定事物的不同位置。所以一座塔会将信息传递给下一座塔，再传给下一座，塔楼里有操作员来操纵这些东西。这是一种在数字时代之前，在非常大的距离上传递信息的惊人方式。
So semiforce actually, the concept goes back to the late 18th century in France. And this man named Claude Shopp invented, basically what it was was like a network of towers on top of these towers They had these sort of wooden structures that could be manipulated to create different positions that would symbolize certain things And so one tower would pass the message on to the next tower Which would pass the message on to the next tower and there were operators and these towers that would manipulate the things And it was this kind of amazing way and a pre-digital age to communicate messages over, you know, really large businesses
就像《指环王》电影里的《王者归来》一样。是的，就像那些烽火，跨越整个山脉，哦，那太酷了。完全正确。我喜欢那个场景。非常鼓舞人心。非常鼓舞人心。国王要来了。对，你知道，这在当时是尽可能快的通讯方式。据说他们可以在十分钟内将信息发送到一百英里外。那太棒了。所以这个概念基本上被改编成了旗语，我想是英国海军军官们，他们基本上用旗子制作了一个手持版本。所以你可以创造这些符号，一艘船上的军官可以与另一艘船上的军官交流，或者与岸上的军官交流，将旗子保持在特定的位置，代表特定的字母，也可能有其他含义。这成为了一种有效的交流手段。
It's like in the return of the king the Lord of the Rings movie Yeah, like the bonfires and then across the whole mountain range and oh, that's so cool exactly. I love I love that scene It's very inspiring. It's very inspiring. The king is coming. Right, and you know, so it was about as fast as communication could happen in this time. They could supposedly send a message a hundred miles and under ten minutes. That's great. And so that concept was basically adapted into the flag language that you know by, I think it was British naval officers
现在它用得不多了。因为显而易见的原因，它相当多余。不过，你有时还是能看到它。在研究这个的时候，我发现马里兰州的海洋城海滩巡逻队，一个超级救生员组织，用它在海滩上传递信息。比如有孩子失踪了，他们会举起旗子，一个传给下一个，然后海滩上的每个人都知道了。那太好了。通常是他们。是的。那么旗语和和平符号有什么关系呢？嗯，杰拉尔德·霍尔顿使用了旗语字母表，基本上是作为他设计的灵感。所以看看这张图。好的，这是一个火柴人，他们的手臂向下，分别在四点钟和八点钟方向，两面旗子向下指，你知道，就像，但不是直接向下。这是一个符号，然后另一个是一个人一只手臂向上，旗子指向上方，另一只手臂指向下方，所以是12点和6点。对。所以，是的，基本上我们都熟悉的和平符号本质上是两个旗语字母。哦。好的。锁在一起，在一个圆圈内。所以你有……你有那个手臂向下的。那是N。是的。
who sort of basically made a handheld version using flags. And so you could create these symbols and an officer on one ship could communicate to an officer on another ship or communicate to an officer on shore and hold the flags in a certain position that meant a certain letter and might have it in another meaning. And this became an effective means of communication.
然后是竖直的。那是D。确实。那么N和D代表什么？核裁军（Nuclear Disarmament）。对。太棒了。是的，这很酷。它是一个如此抽象的物体，你知道。
It's not terribly well used at this point. Any more, you can for obvious reasons. It's fairly redundant. You still do see it, though, sometimes in researching this, I discovered that the Ocean City Beach Patrol in Maryland, a sort of super lifeguard group, uses it to communicate down the beach. That's, you know, also like a child is missing. They'll hold up the flags and one to the next, and then everyone on the beach knows. That's so good. That's often them. Yeah. Yeah. So what does Simifor have to do with the piece symbol? Well, Gerald Holton used the
我从来不知道里面编码了一个字面意思。完全是。我的意思是，我一直把它解释为一架喷气式战斗机。我不知道，那种形状总是让我这么想，我以为它是被讽刺性地挪用为和平，而不是专门针对核裁军之类的。
semifor alphabet, the flag alphabet, basically as inspiration for his design. So take a look at this image. Okay, so it's a stick figure human and they have their arms kind of down at four o'clock and eight o'clock and two flags kind of pointing down, you know, just like, but not directly down. That's one symbol and then the another one is a person with one arm up, the flag pointing up and one arm pointing down, so it's 12 and 6. Right. And so, yeah, so basically the peace sign that we're all familiar with is essentially two
我只是觉得，你知道，我在一个更讽刺的时代长大。所以有讽刺性的符号对我来说完全正常。但它实际上代表N和D的事实真的很酷。它作为一个有直接解释的符号很有效，但如果你不知道这一点，它也同样有效，而大多数人确实不知道。
semifor letters. Oh. Okay. Into locking, so inside a circle. So you've got... You've got the one where the arms are down. That's in. Yeah.
对，这不是常识。有趣的是，霍尔顿本人有多种解读。除了N和D，他说对他来说，它代表了一个人伸出双臂，处于一种绝望的姿势，就像在行刑队面前一样。他提到了像一幅在行刑队面前的人的画，那是一个非常悲伤、绝望的形象。所以他专门为这次游行设计了它，显然他们接受了这个设计。对，对。它非常成功，实际上变成了一年一度的活动。
Then the upright. It's D. And indeed. so what is in D stand for? Nuclear disarmament. Right. It's so good. Yeah. Oh, yeah, it's pretty cool. It's like a such an abstract object, you know.
复活节通常是奥尔德马斯顿大型反核集会的时间。今年比以往任何时候都大，这是他们出发前往50英里外的伦敦游行之前的场景。无论你是否同意他们的观点，这都是一个值得注意的事件。成千上万的英国人参加了这些游行。
I never knew there was like a literal meaning encoded in it. Totally. I mean, I always interpreted it as a jet fighter plane. Like, I don't know, that shape always did, and I thought it was sort of appropriated ironically to mean peace, not specifically to nuclear disarmament or anything.
我学到了一个有趣的事实，年轻的罗德·斯图尔特也参加了。好房间。是的，是的，它们融入了文化之中。有一位非常著名的苏格兰民谣歌手马特·麦金，他写了一首关于他们的歌，叫《从奥尔德马斯顿来的路》。哦，那是一首好歌。他的声音。那真的很好。是的，不是吗？但是，随着奥尔德马斯顿游行成为一年一度的活动，它们开始由一个更大的伞形组织“核裁军运动”来组织，
I just thought it was like, you know, I grew up in a more ironic age. And so having ironic symbols like struck me is totally normal. But the fact that it just stands for N&D together is really cool. It's what works as that with a direct explanation, but it also works if you don't know that, which really most people don't.
这是一个至今仍在英国存在的组织，他们实际上把霍尔顿的和平符号作为他们的官方标志。哦，哇。所以它不仅是一个人们显然随处使用的符号，而且它确实是一个特定组织的官方标志。这真的很特别。那么，它是如何从一个在游行中使用的符号和一个特定组织的标志，变成今天随处可见的图标的呢？是的，这显然不容易回答。任何事物是如何传播的？它会变成一个模因。这不是一件容易解释的事情。但我在研究时偶然发现的一个有趣的小贴士是，民权领袖贝亚德·拉斯汀实际上在第一次奥尔德马斯顿游行上发了言。那个酷儿民权领袖？是的，完全正确。在美国民权运动中经常被低估的人物，马丁·路德·金博士的亲密顾问，
Right, it's not like this is, I mean, I don't think it's common knowledge. It's interesting, Holton himself had sort of multiple interpretations. In addition to the N&D, he said that it sort of to him represented a figure with their arms outstretched in kind of like a despairing position like almost like before a firing squad. He mentioned like a painting with a man before a firing squad was a very like sad despairing image even. So he designed it specifically for this march and obviously they accepted the designs. Right, right. It was super, yeah. The march was very successful and it actually became an annual event.
华盛顿大游行的重要组织者，他当时就在那里。他在第一次游行中，然后你看到和平符号在1960年就开始出现在民权游行中。所以有人推测，可能正是拉斯汀本人将这个标志从英国游行带到了美国的民权游行中。它显然成为了民权游行中经常出现的标志，然后显然真的像滚雪球一样。它成为了美国反越战运动中的一个巨大符号。
Easter time is traditionally the time for the big band, the bomb rally at Oldermaster. It was bigger than ever this year, and this was the scene before they set out on the 50 mile march to London. A note where the event, whether you happen to agree with your viewers or not. Tens of thousands of British people took part in these marches.
每个人都把和平符号当作自己的。对，我的意思是，它只是成为了反主流文化的象征，但我不知道它现在是否还是那样。它被商业利益抓住了，以至于我不知道它是否还像以前那样是一个严肃的符号。是的，这很有趣。
I learned fun fact that a young a young Rod Stewart Participated Good room And yeah, yeah, they became like they became embedded within culture. There's a there's a very famous Scottish folk singer Matt McGinn who wrote a song about them called the road from Altermaston Oh, that's a good bird. He has his voice. That's really nice. Yeah, isn't it great? But yeah, as the Altermasthin marches became this annual event, they started to be organized by this larger umbrella organization called the Campaign for Nuclear Disarmament,
它几乎变得如此无处不在，以至于它失去了一点锋芒。我的意思是，我当然不认为它必然是一个反主流文化的象征。它只是某种东西，你知道，谁不支持和平呢？谁不支持和平符号呢？这很有趣。我记得，你知道，我想我在一年级或二年级的时候，这张我在学校拍照日的照片，背景是激光。我穿着一件傻乎乎的小狩猎背心，戴着一条巨大的和平符号项链。每个人都喜欢和平符号。
which is an organization that still exists to this day in the UK, and they actually have Holtum's peace symbol as their official logo. Oh wow. So it's not just a symbol that, you know, like a symbol that people obviously use everywhere, but it is really an official logo for one individual organization. That's really kind of something. So like, how did it go from being a symbol used in this march and a specific logo for a certain organization to be this icon that is just everywhere today. Yeah, it's obviously not easy to answer that. How does anything spread? It would become a meme. It's not an easy thing to explain. But one little interesting
我有很多。我的意思是，不是那种味道，而是半美元大小的。那很不错。是的，我肯定在初中和高中时有一条和平符号项链。是的，完全是。是的，它到处都是。也许比现在更多，但很疯狂。当然在我们心爱的东湾看到很多。肯定的。
tip that I came across as I was researching was that the civil rights leader, Bired Rustin, actually spoke at that first, Alder-Maston March. So the queer civil rights leader? Yeah, exactly. Very often under appreciated figure in the American civil rights movement, close advisor to Dr. King,
作为一个思考设计和标志的人，你有什么想法，为什么它会成功？作为标志，作为一件设计作品，它有什么好之处？我的意思是，我认为它真的很容易画。它非常引人注目。它是一个足够抽象的图像，你可以注入意义，而且它似乎保留了那种意义，即使它超越了核裁军，变成了像一般的和平。在很多方面，比如方向，它不需要完全竖直才能起作用，事实上，稍微倾斜一点，看起来也很好。是的，这很有趣。关于这一点，我喜欢，我和这位和平符号的历史学家谈过，他的名字叫肯·科尔斯本德，
important organizer of the March on Washington, and he was there. He was at that first March, and then you see the piece symbol starts showing up in civil rights marches and as early as 1960. And so there is some speculation that it might have actually been rust in himself who brought this logo from these British marches to civil rights marches in the US. It obviously became the often featured in civil rights marches and then obviously really snowballed. it became a huge symbol in the anti-war movement in the United States with Vietnam.
他写了一本详细记录所有这些历史的好书。他说杰拉尔德·霍尔顿本人后来认为它应该完全倒过来，这样从中心线出来的两条线应该向上呈45度角。形成一个Y。形成一个Y，我想他的部分理由是它看起来几乎像一棵树。哦，来吧。然后是一个更有希望的符号。是的。
Everyone sort of took on the piece symbol as their own. Right, I mean, it became just a symbol of counter-culturalism, but I don't know if it's really that as much anymore. Like it got grabbed onto by commercial interests to such an extent that I don't know if it's as serious a symbol as it once was. Yeah, it's interesting.
但另一件事，我认为非常有趣，是那样的话，在旗语中，字母是B-A-U。哦，不是一个人。好吧，不是敌人，他将其视为普遍裁军，而不是核裁军，当你思考时，这很酷，我的意思是，并不是说这没有真正发生。大多数人确实让它指向下方，但我认为，你知道，在他心中，它比英国不发展核武器要大得多。它是关于世界和平的，这正是它后来所象征的。
It was almost like, so ubiquitous that it lost its edge a little bit. I mean, I certainly don't think of it as a counter-cultural symbol, necessarily. It's sort of just something, you know, who doesn't support peace? Who doesn't support the peace symbol? It's funny. I remember, you know, as like, I think I was in first or second grade, this picture of me from school picture day behind the laser background. I'm wearing this goofy little safari vest and this massive pea-sign necklace. Everyone loves pea-sign.
是的。所以无论你是否翻转它，那种意图仍然存在。我想是的。这很棒。我的意思是，这意味着他创造了一个经得起时间考验的符号，无论你是否翻转它。对，我的意思是，你不会，一旦你创造了某种东西，它被吸收到文化中，达到和平符号那样的程度，
I got massive flavor. I mean, not like flavor, but I don't dollar, half dollar side. That's pretty good. Yeah, I'm certain I had a peace sign necklace when I was in junior high and high school. Yeah, totally. Yeah, it was just everywhere. Maybe even more so than now, but crazy. Certainly see a lot of them around our beloved East Bay. For sure.
你不能确切地翻转它。你不能在五年后把它翻过来。它已经消失了。现在它是别人的了。它属于世界。它属于世界，是的。那太酷了。好的，谢谢。
Do you have any thoughts, like as someone who thinks about design and logos on like why this was successful? Like what's good about it as a logo, as a piece of design? I mean, I think it's really easy to draw. It's really striking. It is enough of an abstract image that you can pour meaning into and it seemed to retain that meaning even though it went beyond nuclear disarmament and went to like, peace in general. In lots of ways, like the orientation, like it doesn't have to be perfectly upright for it to work in fact, like a little bit tilted, it looks good in either way. Yeah, it's interesting. On that, I like, I talked to this historian of the piece symbol, his name is Ken Colesbund
谢谢。特别感谢肯·科尔斯本德，他与埃米特谈论了和平符号。他写了一本好书。书名叫《和平：一个符号的传记》，你可以在我们的网站上找到链接。所以我和薇薇安·李在演播室，你今天要告诉我们什么无处不在的图标？所以这个故事实际上来自我们的一位听众，名叫莫妮卡·米纳尔，顺便说一句，她很棒。我们有一些非常酷的听众。完全是。她现在住在温哥华。
and he wrote a great book detailing all this history. And he said that Gerard Holcomb, actually himself, came to think that it should be flipped completely upside down, so that the two lines coming off of the center line would be facing upward at 45 degrees. Forming a Y. Forming a Y, and I think part of his reasoning was that it would look almost like a tree. Oh, come. And then a sort of a more hopeful symbol there. Yeah.
但在2004年，她在马来西亚吉隆坡的一家律师事务所工作，从事知识产权商标方面的工作。所以我的工作基本上是查看或创建商标申请，或者写声明给注册官。我保证这个故事会变得更有趣。她会进行商标申请。是的，请不要做更多。
But the other thing, which I think is pretty interesting, was that then it would, in semifor, letter is B-A-U. Oh, not a man. Well, not an enemy he saw as universal this armament, instead of nuclear disarmament, which it's pretty cool when you think, I mean, not that this hasn't actually happened. Most people do keep it pointed down, but I think that, you know, in his mind, it was bigger than just, you know, Britain not developing nuclear weapons. It was about like world peace, which is exactly kind of what, what it has come to symbolize.
哦，天哪。但是，是的，好吧。所以我会的。所以是的，它会变得更有趣。我保证。这是我名字的基石。所以是的，它会变得更有趣。我保证这是我名字的基石。这是一个经典的99 PI剧集。我们要谈论知识产权，这会很棒。这会很棒。我毫无疑问。继续。是的。所以我只是觉得我们必须
Yeah. So whether or not you flip it or not, it really is that intent is still there. I think so. Which is pretty great. I mean, it means that he created a symbol that stood the test of time, whether you flip it or not. Right, I mean, you don't, once you create something and it gets sucked into culture to the degree
在最开始澄清几件事。其中之一是商标到底是什么。商标基本上是文字或声音、字母或设计，或者是它们全部或部分的组合，以在市场上将一个人的商品或服务与所有其他商品或服务区分开来。所以，如果你是一家公司，你可以在商标局注册一个商标或标志。那个标志应该是你的商品和服务的代表。因此，当这个标记与你的产品联系在一起时，它就与你的品牌声誉联系在一起了。明白了。好的。到目前为止我明白了。好的。所以如果有人想注册商标，他们必须提交审查。
that the piece symbol did, you don't exactly get to flip it. You don't get to flip it on its head like five years later. It was gone. It's everyone else's now. It belongs to the world. It belongs to the world, yeah. That's so cool. All right, thanks.
但如果已经存在一个现有的商标，并且所有者认为你的商标与他们的太相似，他们可以提出反对。例如，如果你采用99 PI标志，就像带有黄色方块的黑色网格，那个标志与你的工作相关，对吧？所以想象一个非常非常糟糕的播客出来了。是的，很难想象一个糟糕的播客，但请继续。好的，所以想象有一个糟糕的聊天播客。
Thank you. Special thanks to Ken Colzman, who spoke with Emmett about the piece symbol. He wrote a great book. It's called Peace, the biography of a symbol, which you can find a link to on our website. So I'm in the studio with Vivine Leigh and what is your ubiquitous icon? You're going to tell us about today. So this story actually came from one of our listeners, named Monica Minar, who is awesome, by the way. We have some really cool listeners. Totally. And she lives in Vancouver now.
他们的标志非常相似，就像一个带有稍微不同黄色的黑色网格，无论什么，他们可能会看到那个并认为它是99 PI的工作，然后你的声誉会受到他们标志的负面影响。完全是，这就是你拥有商标保护的全部原因。混淆消费者是商标保护的核心。是的，完全正确。你说对了。所以莫妮卡写信给我们，因为她在2004年处理过一个特别的案例，它在她的脑海里停留了大约15年。
But back in 2004, she was working for a law firm in Kuala Lumpur, Malaysia, in intellectual property under trademarks. So my job was basically to look at either a create trademark applications or write statements to the registrar. And I promise that the story is going to get more interesting. She will trade more applications. Yes, please don't do more.
所以我不知道你是否熟悉公文教育中心，但它基本上就像一个教育中心特许经营，基本上是一堆辅导学校。好的。好的。所以他们试图注册一个商标标志，但遭到了另一家公司的反对。我们收到了另一家公司关于我们为公文教育中心注册商标的反对声明。他们被发送了一份反对意见，说公文的标志与他们已经注册的商标太相似了，也就是笑脸。就像经典的笑脸，大黄圆圈，椭圆形的眼睛和一个半圆形的
Oh man. But yeah, okay. So I will. So yes, it will get more interesting. I promise. This is the cornerstone of my name. So yes, it will get more interesting. I promise this is the cornerstone of my name. This is a classic 999 PI episode. We're going to talk about IP and it's going to be great. It's going to be great. I have no doubt in my mind. Keep going. Yeah. So I just feel like we have to
嘴巴向上。是的，完全正确。如果你想到笑脸，那就是反对这个教育中心的公司。我的意思是，这当然有资格成为一个无处不在的图标，但我完全没想到它会被一家公司拥有，以至于他们会发生商标纠纷，甚至被任何人设计。它似乎只是一个存在的东西。
clarify a couple things right up top. And one of them is what a trademark actually is. A trademark is basically words or sounds, letters or a design or a combination of all or a few of them to distinguish one's goods or services from all others in the marketplace. So, if you're a company, you could register a trademark or like a logo with a trademark office. And that logo is supposed to be representative of your goods and service. And so, as this mark becomes associated with your product, it becomes tied to the reputation of your brand. Got it. Okay. Got you so far. Okay. So if someone wants to register a trademark, they have to submit it for review.
它就在那里，它无处不在，它在一切东西上。完全正确。所以我实际上应该给你看公文标志是什么样子的。所以那里有一张照片，对吧？哦，好的。所以它写着公文，O是一个脸，它没有笑。它只是一个非常简单的圆圈和一条直线，像沉思一样，它看起来像一个90年代的卡通头，你知道，它不是真的，嗯，它不是真的在笑。是的。是的。是的。是的。对我来说，它看起来更像左洛复卡通，而不是真正的笑脸。
But if there's an existing trademark already, and the owner thinks that your trademark is too similar to theirs, they can oppose it. For example, if you take the 9.9 PI logo, which is like the black grid with the yellow square, that logo is associated with your work, right? So imagine a really, really bad podcast comes out. Yeah, it's hard to imagine a bad podcast, but go ahead. Okay, so imagine there's like a terrible chatty podcast.
我们就像，你看不见世界上的太阳，因为你抑郁。完全正确。它有一点那种氛围。它也只是有一点，你知道，它看起来很酷。我认为这是一个好标志。它是。这是一个好标志，我喜欢它。是的。
And there are logos very similar, like it's a black grid with like a slightly different yellow, whatever, they might see that and think it's a black grid with like a slightly different yellow, you know, whatever They might see that and think it's 99 PIs work and then your reputation would be negatively affected by their logo Totally, that's that's the whole reason why you have trademark protection Confusing the consumer is the heart of trademark protection. Yes, exactly You got it. So Monica basically wrote to us because there's this one case in particular that she worked on back in 2004 And it's been stuck in her head for like the last 15 years
但公文教育中心遭到了笑脸公司的反对，该公司由一位名叫富兰克林·卢弗罗尼的记者创立，现在由他的儿子尼古拉斯·卢弗罗尼经营。所以他们在1971年注册了笑脸商标。所以他们基本上把商业用途的权利授权给利维斯或糖果公司，或者基本上任何想使用该设计的人。但你想知道我在研究这个故事时学到的最奇怪的事情吗？当然。好的，如果你去尼古拉斯·卢弗罗尼的领英页面，他的官方头衔是“敬爱的领袖”
So I don't know if you're familiar with the Kumon Institute, but it's basically like an education center franchise Like a bunch of like tutoring schools basically. Okay. Okay. So they were trying to register a trademark logo But they were being opposed by another company We got a statement of opposition from another company regarding one of our registrations for a trademark for the Kumon Institute. They were sent a opposition to say that Kumon's logo is too similar to their already registered trademark, which is the smiley face. As in like the classic smiley face, like big yellow circle to oval eyes and a semi-circle
在笑脸公司。哦，敬爱的领袖。这有点……看起来不太好。有点像朝鲜。哦，天哪。我的意思是，他可能是一个令人愉快的人，这可能只是为了好玩，或者其他什么，但那绝对是独裁统治。这对我个人来说是那种尖叫，但你知道，你知道，无论他喜欢什么。
mouth pointing up. Yes, exactly. If you think about a smiley face, that is the company that was opposing this education center. I mean, this certainly qualifies as a ubiquitous icon, but I totally didn't think that it could be owned by one company such that they would have a trademark dispute or even designed by anyone. It just seems like a thing that exists.
随他去吧。是的，所以知道，知道那个，无论他喜欢什么，随他去吧。是的，所以知道那个，这实际上不是卢弗罗尼第一次试图阻止另一个商标。他还试图阻止乔·拳击手，我不确定你是否熟悉。是的，完全。内衣公司，他们的标志基本上是一个伸出舌头的笑脸。
It's just there, it's everywhere, it's on everything. Exactly. So I should actually show you what the Kumon logo looks like. So there's a photo there, right? Oh, okay. So it says Kumon and the O is a face, It's not smiling. It's just like a very simple circle and a kind of straight line like Pensive, it looks like a, the head of a 90s, you know, a cartoon head, you know, like it's not really, um, it's not really smiling. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Like to me, it kind of looks more like the the zooloft cartoon than an actual smiley face.
他们还与沃尔玛进行了长达数年的斗争，因为沃尔玛在回滚活动中使用笑脸。哦，完全。是的，就像漂浮着并改变沃尔玛的价格。是的。是的。那个家伙因为与卢弗罗尼的法律斗争而消失了一段时间。那么笑脸最初是由卢弗罗尼创造的，还是他只是第一个注册商标的人？你看？这就是问题所在。好的。因为即使卢弗罗尼是第一个注册该标记的人，他绝对不是第一个声称创造它的人。
We're just like, you can't see the sun in the world because you're depression. Exactly. It has a little bit of that vibe. It also just has a little bit of like, you know, it's cool looking actually. I think it's a good logo. It is. It's a good logo I like it. Yeah.
有记录可以追溯到1600年代，基本上是笑脸符号的某种变体被使用。但最被广泛接受的关于谁发明了我们今天所知的经典黄色笑脸的理论，是一个名叫哈维·罗斯·鲍尔的人在1963年。他被一家保险公司聘请来提高士气。所以他被聘请来创造某种设计，他们可以应用在
But the Kumon Institute was being opposed by the smiley company, which was founded by journalist named Franklin Lufroni, and now it's run by his son Nicholas Lufroni. So they registered the Smiley Face trademark in 1971. So they basically licensed the rights for commercial purposes to leave eyes or candy companies or basically anybody that wants to use the design. But do you want to know the weirdest thing that I learned while researching this story? Definitely. Okay, so if you go to Nicholas Lufroni's LinkedIn page, his official title is Beloved Leader
按钮和其他可能的材料上。所以鲍尔是一位在伍斯特的自由艺术家。伍斯特，马萨诸塞州，杂烩，红袜队。大约在这个时候，州互助人寿保险公司与他们的竞争对手之一合并了。我想每次合并时，都会有很多裁员和悲伤。是的，肯定的。是的。所以州互助公司所做的是，他们聘请鲍尔为他们正在发起的友谊运动设计这个标志。所以他们只是把它贴在按钮和海报上，分发给员工和客户
at the Smiley Company. Oh, Beloved Leader. It's kind of... Not a good look. A little North Korean. Oh goodness. I mean, he could be a delightful fellow and this could be just kind of having fun or whatever, but like that is definitely Dictatorial rule. It's because that's what that screams to me personally, but you know, you know, whatever whatever he enjoys.
等等。老实说，设计并没有花太多心思，因为鲍尔说他花了大约10分钟就做出了这个设计，他为此获得了45美元。但运动有点像在增长，你知道，按钮开始流行起来，州互助公司实际上卖出了数千个这样的笑脸按钮。
Go with God. Yeah, so knowing knowing that Whenever he enjoys, go with God. Yeah, so knowing that, this actually wasn't the first time that Lufroni tried to block another trademark. He also tried to block a Joe Boxer, which I'm not sure if you're familiar with. Yeah, totally. The Underwear Company, and their logo is basically a smiley face with a tongue sticking out.
但州互助公司或鲍尔都没有给这个标志注册商标。你听说过笑脸被称为“祝你有美好的一天”吗？这听起来有点耳熟，但没有。我总是叫它笑脸。是的，这有点像伴随笑脸的口号。所以有些人可能会把它识别为“祝你有美好的一天”，而不是笑脸。好的，这使它像“祝你有美好的一天”，而不是像笑脸。
And they were also involved in a year's long battle with Walmart because Walmart uses the smiley face in the rollback campaigns. Oh, totally. Yeah, like floats around and changes the prices on the Walmart. Yeah. Yeah. That guy disappeared for a while because of this legal battle with Lufrani. So was the smiley face originally created by Lufrani or was he just the first person to trademark it? You see? That is the question. Okay. Because even though Lufroni was the first to register the mark, he's definitely not the first person to claim to have created it.
好的，这说得通。所以“祝你有美好的一天”笑脸本质上与鲍尔的笑脸设计相同。但它被归功于两个名叫伯纳德和默里·斯佩恩的兄弟。所以1970年，他们基本上只是拿走了鲍尔的设计，并用“祝你有美好的一天”这句话卖给了家庭作业。这就是笑脸
There's like accounts that go back to the 1600s, basically, of some variation of a smiling face symbol being used. But the most widely accepted theory of who invented that classic yellow smiley face, as we know it today, was a man named Harvey Ross Ball in 1963. He was hired by an insurance company to improve morale. So he was hired to create some kind of a design that they can apply on
射入那个模糊的流行文化平流层的地方。对。因为它最终出现在杯子、T恤、保险杠贴纸、耳环上，它成为了某种商品化和大规模生产的化身。而且因为笑脸无处不在，在一切东西上，笑脸背后的意义，你知道，只是很容易被腐蚀。
buttons and other maybe materials. So Ball was a freelance artist based in Worcester. Worcester, Massachusetts, Chowda, Sox. And around this time, State Mutual Life Insurance merged with one of their competitors. And every time that you have a merger, I guess, there's a lot of layoffs and sadness. Yeah, for sure. Yeah. So what State Mutual did was they hired Ball to come up with this logo for a friendship campaign that they were launching. So they just like slapped it on buttons and posters and handed that out to like staff and clients
所以就像1972年，它被讽刺地刊登在《疯狂杂志》的封面上。阿尔弗雷德·E·纽曼的脸被合成在黄色笑脸上。对，对，对。但你知道死肯尼迪乐队的歌《加州优步阿利斯》吗？什么？是的。我知道死肯尼迪乐队的歌《加州优步阿利斯》。了解一点你的音乐品味。
and that sort of thing. And honestly, not a ton of thought went into the design because Balsa that he mocked up the design about like 10 minutes and he was paid $45 for it. But the campaign sort of like growing and you know, the buttons started catching on in state mutual sort of selling actually like thousands of these smiley face buttons.
你离被解雇从来没有比现在更近了。你想让我唱完所有六段，还是你想让我唱第一段？我可以吗？我有点想看看你能走多远。证明它，证明它，证明它。我是杰里·布朗州长。我的O'R，我的Oroz英里，从不皱眉。很快我将成为总统。我是杰里·布朗州长，我的Oroz英里，从不皱眉。
But neither state mutual or ball trademarked the logo. Have you ever heard of the smiley face being referred to as have a nice day? That sounds vaguely familiar, but no. I would always call it a smiley face. Yeah, it's kind of like a slogan that went with the smiling face. So some people might recognize it as have a nice day rather than the smiley face. OK, that makes it as like, have a nice day rather than like the smiley face.
很快我将成为总统。哦，Resa，Dundes。是的，我知道《加州优步阿利斯》这首歌。好的，所以这是79年，1979年左右。所以这首歌是关于杰里·布朗统治的嬉皮法西斯国家。单曲艺术，看起来杰里·布朗是独裁者，就像纽伦堡式的集会，而在他身后是禁止的。万字旗，有笑脸。是的，是的，是的，是的，所以它就像这个
Okay, that makes sense. So the have a nice day smiley face is essentially the same design as ball smiley face. But instead it's credited to these two brothers name Bernard and Murray Spain. So in 1970, they basically just took ball's design and sold it to Homework with the phrase have a nice day. And this is kind of the point where the smiley face
它有点进入了这个腐败阶段。是的，有一种邪恶的品质。有一种邪恶的。完全正确，是的，然后笑脸再次被艾伦·摩尔的《守望者》挪用。哦，是的，完全，而且当时它显然已经很令人毛骨悚然了。然后他加上了那抹血，这成为了《守望者》的象征。而喜剧演员，你知道，那是他的象征，
shot into that nebulous pop culture stratosphere. Right. Because it ends up on like mugs, t-shirts, bumper stickers, earrings, and it becomes sort of this embodiment of merchandising and mass production. And because the smiley face was everywhere and on everything, the meaning behind the smiley face was, you know, just easily corrupted.
是一个有严重缺陷和糟糕的角色。而笑脸是这个，你知道，有点讽刺，但也几乎不是。就像，我甚至不知道。就像，它已经被腐蚀到一定程度，我甚至不知道喜剧演员作为一个角色在多大程度上颠覆了它。是的。我不知道。
So like in 1972, it was featured satirically on the cover of Mad Magazine. There was like a composite image of Alfredi Newman's face on a yellow smiley face. Right, right, right. But do you know the song California Uber Alice by the Dead Kennedys? What? Yes. I know the song California U-R-A-S by the Dead Kennedys. Knowing a little bit about your music taste.
当你看到《守望者》笑脸时，你不会祝你有美好的一天。你不会。还有那种暴力。这是一部让你感觉不好的图画小说。是的。是的。所以作为一件艺术品，它非常刺耳，以一种好的方式。是的，当你读《守望者》时，那个笑脸就与那种不适联系在一起了。完全是。
You've never come closer to being fired than you are right now. Do you want me to sing all six verses or do you want me to sing the first one? Can I? I kind of want to see how far you go. Let's prove it, prove it, prove it. I am Governor Jerry Brown. My O'R, my Oroz Miles and Never Frowns. Soon I will be President. I am Governor Jerry Brown, my Oroz Miles and Never Frowns.
是的。但一旦你开始进入80年代，笑脸就离上帝越来越远，因为酸性浩室音乐和狂欢派对开始接管英国。我不确定你在狂欢派对上花了多少时间。不，不多。那里往往有很多毒品使用。你没有。天哪，可耻。
Soon I will be President. Oh, Resa, Dundes. Yes, I know the song California River Ellis. Okay, so this is like 79, 1979-ish. So the song is about like this hippie-fascist state run by Jerry Brown. The single art, it kind of looks like Jerry Brown is the dictator and it's like a Nuremberg-style rally and instead behind him it's banished. Swastika's there's smiley faces. Yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's like this
我的意思是，我只是想提醒你，在狂欢派对上，有时会有毒品。在许多这些狂欢派对上，药丸上会印有笑脸设计。是的。是的。所以就像在80年代和90年代的美国，笑脸只是与这种狂欢文化和非法毒品文化联系在一起。但是的，所以它就像，它离它开始的地方很远。是的，它只是承担了，它就像豆腐。它只是在这一点上吸收了它周围任何东西的味道。你知道，因为这就是它的方式，它是图标豆腐。那太棒了。但是，是的，所以戴夫·吉本斯，他是插画家。是的，他是《守望者》的插画家
it's kind of entering this corruption phase. Yeah where there's a sinister quality. There's a sinister. Exactly yeah and then the smiley face is repropriated again by Alan Moore's Watchman. Oh yeah totally and it was it was clearly already creepy then. And then he adds that splash of blood, which becomes the symbol for Watchmen. And the comedian, who's, you know, like that's the his symbol,
他实际上是这样评价笑脸的，我真的很喜欢，他说它只是一个带有三个标记的黄色区域。它再简单不过了，所以在某种程度上它是空的，准备好注入意义。它再简单不过了。所以在某种程度上它是空的，准备好注入意义。如果你把它放在托儿所环境里，它很合适。如果你把它拿走，放在右边警察的防毒面具上，那么它就变成了完全不同的东西。这就是莫妮卡用来反对
is a deeply flawed and awful character. And the Smiley Faces, this, you know, kind of ironic, but also almost not. Like, I don't even know. Like, it's already pre-corrupted to an extent that I don't even know how much the comedian as a character is subverting it. Yeah. I don't know.
卢弗罗尼和笑脸公司反对公文标志的论点之一。哦，那真的很有趣。她是怎么做到的？所以如果你记得，商标应该是产品的独特代表，对吧？是的。但笑脸是如此无处不在，并且以如此多不同的竞争方式被使用，以至于作为笑脸公司的商标，
You don't have a nice day when you see the watchman smiley face. You do not. And also just the violence of that. It's a graphic novel that kind of makes you feel bad. Yeah. Yeah. So it's very jarring as a piece of art in a good way. Yeah, when you read Watchmen, that smiley face becomes associated with that discomfort. Totally.
它并没有真正持有任何与笑脸公司或卢弗罗尼本人的联系。这对卢弗罗尼来说实际上是一个问题，因为它现在被广泛使用。最有可能的是，大多数人甚至从未听说过这个名字与笑脸联系在一起。是的，我的意思是，我想可能大多数人把笑脸标志归功于《阿甘正传》，而不是卢弗罗尼或与之相关的任何其他东西。是的，在我开始这个故事之前，
Yeah. But once you start getting into the 80s, the smiley face kind of just strays further and further away from God because acid house music and raves start taking over the UK. And I'm not sure how much time you've spent at raves. No, not very much. There tends to be a lot of drug use happening there. You don't. God, scandalous.
我会说《阿甘正传》制作了笑脸。所以她赢了吗？她赢了，是的，那是公文目前的标志。他们无法阻止他们。哦，好吧，酷，给你。是的，好吧，那太棒了。好吧，谢谢莫妮卡写信进来。是的，如果你有一份有趣的工作，你做了一些很酷的事情。
I mean, I just wanted to caution you that at raves, sometimes there's drugs. And at a lot of these raves, the pills would be printed with the smiley face design on them. Yeah. Yeah. So like in the 80s and in the 90s in the United States, the smiley face was kind of just associated with this rave culture and like illicit drug culture. But yeah, so it's like, it's gone, it's far from where it started. Yeah, and it just kind of takes on, it's like tofu. It just takes on the flavor of whatever is around it at this point. You know, because it's just that's just the way it is It's icon tofu. That's great But yeah, so Dave Gibbons who was the illustrator. Yeah, he was the illustrator of watchman
是的，即使它不有趣，但背后有一个完整的故事。那是对的。是的，无聊的工作，但背后有一个有趣的故事。联系我们。这是你的家。这是你的家。这是你的家。谢谢大家。
He actually said this of the smiley face, which I really like he said it's just a yellow field with three marks on it It couldn't be more simple and so did that degree It's empty and ready for meaning if you on it. It couldn't be more simple. And so did that degree. It's empty and ready for meaning. If you put it in a nursery setting, it fits in well. If you take it and put it on a right policeman's gas mask, then it becomes something completely different. And this is kind of one of the arguments that Monica used
谢谢。之后我会谈谈权力的象征。所以我和库尔特·科尔斯特德在演播室，你有一个你想谈论的图标。哦，是的，是的，伙计。好的，它是什么？是的，它通常被称为电源图标，但它也正式被称为待机符号。哦，好的。这就是你在电脑上会看到的，例如。
against Lufraani and the Smiley Company when they tried to oppose the coupons on logo. Oh, that's really interesting. How did she do that? So if you remember, a trademark is supposed to be like a distinct representation of a product or a company, right? Yeah. But the smiley face is so ubiquitous and has been used in so many different competing ways that as a trademark for the smiley company,
哦，是的。如果你在电脑周围花过任何时间，你都见过这样的电源按钮。是的。它非常常见，而且非常具体。它基本上只是一个顶部有缺口的圆圈。然后有一条竖线穿过圆圈的中心和那个缺口。
it doesn't really hold any association to the smiley company or to Lufrai himself. That is actually a problem for Lufroni because it is now of such widespread use. It is most probable that most people have never even heard of the name being associated with the smiley face. Yeah, I mean, like, I think probably most people attribute the smiley face logo to Forrest Gump, then Lufroni or anything else related to it. Yes, and before I started the story,
是的，这几乎就是你在每台电脑上看到的。你按下按钮启动电脑，或者让它进入睡眠状态，或者关机，等等。是的，是的，是的。它看起来有点抽象。就像看起来不像任何特别的东西。但它也是那些无处不在的图标之一，就像我们一直在谈论的那些，
I would have said Forrest Gump made the smiley face. So does she win? She did, yeah, and that is the current logo for Cuman. They couldn't stop them. Oh, well cool, there you go. Yeah, well, that's awesome. Well, thanks Monica for writing in. Yeah, if you have an interesting job, you've done something cool.
它似乎很有意义，尽管我从来没有真正想过它有多抽象或它有多字面意思。是的，是的。你从上下文中学习它。你一遍又一遍地看到它。你就像，是的，那是电源按钮。对。
Yeah, even if it's not interesting, but there's a full story behind it. That's right. Yeah, boring job, but there's an interesting story behind it. Hit us up. This is your home. This is your home. This is your home. Thanks, everyone.
是的，即使它不那么有趣，但背后有一个完整的故事。没错。是的，枯燥的工作，但背后有一个有趣的故事。联系我们吧。这是你的家。这是你的家。这是你的家。谢谢大家。
Thank you. I'll talk about the symbol of power after this. So I'm in the studio with Kurt Colstead and you have an icon that you want to talk about. Oh yes, yeah, dude. Okay, what is it? Yeah, it's typically called the power icon, but it's also officially known as the standby symbol. Oh, okay. This is what you would see on a computer, for example.
谢谢。接下来我将谈谈电源图标。我和库尔特·科尔斯特德在演播室里，你有一个想谈论的图标。哦，是的，伙计。好的，那是什么？是的，它通常被称为电源图标，但官方名称是待机符号。哦，好的。这就是你在电脑上看到的，例如。
Oh, yeah. If you've spent any time at all around computers, you've seen power buttons like this. Yeah. It's very common and it's like very specific. It's basically just a circle with a gap at the top. And then there's this vertical line that runs up through the center of the circle and through that gap.
哦，是的。如果你在电脑周围待过一段时间，你一定见过这样的电源按钮。是的。它非常普遍，而且非常具体。它基本上就是一个顶部有缺口的圆圈。然后有一条垂直线穿过圆圈的中心并穿过那个缺口。
Yeah, this is pretty much what you see on every computer. You press the button to start the computer or to put it to sleep or turn it off or that sort of thing. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And it looks sort of abstract. Like doesn't look like anything in particular. But it's also one of those ubiquitous icons that like the ones we've been talking about that,
是的，这几乎是你每台电脑上都能看到的。你按下按钮来启动电脑，或者让它进入睡眠状态，或者关机，诸如此类。是的，是的，是的。它看起来有点抽象。看起来不像任何特定的东西。但它也是我们一直在谈论的那种无处不在的图标之一，
it seems to make sense as to what it is, even though I've never really thought about how abstract it is or how literal it is at all. Yeah, yeah. You learn it from context. You see it over and over again. You're like, yeah, that's a power button. Right.
它似乎让人明白它是做什么的，尽管我从来没有真正想过它有多抽象或者它到底有多直观。是的，是的。你是从语境中学会的。你一遍又一遍地看到它。你会想，是的，那是电源按钮。没错。
But it's actually based on binary notation. So essentially, binary is about on states and off states, which are usually represented by ones and zeros. And those, of course, look a lot like vertical lines and circles. Okay, so like the circle is the zero that indicates off, and then the line part, the vertical line, is the one, and then indicates on. But why is the line breaking up the circle like it is on a power button? Well, so that's why this is called the standby symbol because it's not a complete power on
但它实际上是基于二进制记数法的。所以本质上，二进制是关于开状态和关状态的，通常用 1 和 0 来表示。当然，它们看起来很像垂直线和圆圈。好吧，圆圈就是代表关的 0，而线条部分，即垂直线，就是代表开的 1。但为什么线条会像电源按钮上那样把圆圈切开呢？嗯，这就是为什么它被称为待机符号，因为它不是一个完整的电源开启
off symbol. And it's used mostly to put devices to sleep and to wake them back up again. So it doesn't actually physically cut off power going to a device. It's not like pulling the plug or removing the battery or something. But I also feel like I've seen the general use of circle and a line on other types of power switches and stuff like that. Is that common? Yeah, you definitely have. There's a bunch of power-related symbols that all use lines and circles. So sometimes you'll see a switch, for example, with a line on one side and a circle on the other. And that's like a hard on off switch. Right.
关闭符号。它主要用于让设备进入睡眠状态并再次唤醒它们。所以它实际上并没有物理切断流向设备的电源。这不像拔掉插头或取出电池之类的操作。但我也觉得我在其他类型的电源开关上见过圆圈和线条的通用用法。这很常见吗？是的，你肯定见过。有一堆与电源相关的符号都使用了线条和圆圈。所以有时你会看到一个开关，例如，一边有一条线，另一边有一个圆圈。那就像是一个硬开关。没错。
You can find similar buttons that wear like the circle completely encloses the line. So that way there's no ambiguity. You know, like this is going to turn something completely on or completely off. So once you set this connection between the binary zero and one, all these other power buttons pretty much make sense.
你可以找到类似的按钮，圆圈完全包围了线条。这样就不会有歧义。你知道，就像这会把某样东西完全打开或完全关闭。所以一旦你建立了二进制 0 和 1 之间的这种联系，所有这些其他的电源按钮就基本说得通了。
They have a little bit of variation, but they pretty much are that. But there's also, I mean, I remember when I was a kid, like Boomboxes had a switcher, more like a light switch, where it would say on and off or on a stereo, it would be a push button, but it would say power. I think that's kind of gone away over time, or it's less over time.
它们有一点点变化，但基本就是那样。但我记得我小时候，比如手提音响有一个开关，更像是一个电灯开关，上面会写着开和关，或者在立体声设备上，它会是一个按钮，但上面会写着电源。我想随着时间的推移，这种情况已经消失了，或者越来越少了。
Yeah, it was like a really common thing for a long time to use English language labels, which people could read. But in the mid-1900s, the late 1900s, as electronics started to get made around the world and then shipped around the world, languages became sort of a barrier, right? You needed something more universal. Also, if you think about it, words take up a lot of space compared to symbols. So this is where the IEC comes in. And that's the nonprofit International Electro Technical Commission. And in the 1970s, they published this document called Graphical Symbols for Use on Equip equipment. Yeah, with you. Then, then.
是的，长期以来，使用人们可以阅读的英语标签是一件非常普遍的事情。但在 20 世纪中叶到末期，随着电子产品开始在世界各地制造并运往世界各地，语言成为了一种障碍，对吧？你需要一些更通用的东西。另外，如果你仔细想想，与符号相比，文字占用了很大的空间。这就是 IEC 发挥作用的地方。那是一个非营利性的国际电工委员会。在 20 世纪 70 年代，他们发布了一份名为《设备用图形符号》的文件。是的，我同意。
Okay. Oh, this is cool. And this is just like a sampling of what this is. I just printed out a couple of pages. Right. You see like a gas tank, a symbol for a hood, on a car, and a trunk, like opening, seat belt sign, oil sign, battery sign. These are all, you recognize these all on the dashboard of a car.
好的。哦，这太酷了。这只是其中的一小部分。我刚打印了几页。你看，像油箱、汽车引擎盖的符号，还有后备箱、开启、安全带标志、机油标志、电池标志。这些你都能在汽车仪表盘上认出来。
You can tell a bunch of nerds put this together because there's like, they all like fit. They all work at this size. You know what I mean? They're all like very uniform in size and they convey information in that size, like a lot of information. But they are really kind of different to you. You know? Yeah.
你可以看出是一群书呆子把这些东西放在一起的，因为它们都很合适。它们在这个尺寸下都能正常工作。你知道我的意思吗？它们在尺寸上非常统一，并且在那个尺寸下传达了信息，传达了大量信息。但它们对你来说确实有点不同。你知道吗？是的。
And the IEC came up with some of these, but a lot of them they just adopted or adapted from what was already being widely used and then they just folded them into this huge set of recommended standards. They look kind of like tech hieroglyphics. They convey a lot of information if you put them all together It almost tells a little story, especially I'm not the best at maintaining my car So various lights are on in my car at all times. So I'm familiar with a lot of these symbols. Yeah, yeah. And the idea is that they are supposed to be familiar and they're supposed to work
IEC 想出了一些，但其中很多是他们直接采用或改编自已经广泛使用的符号，然后将它们整合到这套庞大的推荐标准中。它们看起来有点像科技象形文字。如果你把它们放在一起，它们传达了大量信息，几乎讲述了一个小故事，尤其是因为我不擅长保养我的车，所以我的车里一直亮着各种灯。所以我对很多这些符号都很熟悉。是的，是的。而且它们的理念是它们应该是熟悉的，并且应该在
across languages and at different scales. Be as intuitive and universal as possible. So if you travel to another country and drive a car and you see a light come on, hopefully, you'll also know what's wrong in that, the other country. Right. And as part of making the universal and understandable, the IEC goes out of its way to create these visually similar sets or families of symbols. And so that way once you understand one of them, you can start to make guesses about what other symbols would look like. Yeah, so I'm flipping through and I recognize a lot of these symbols, but the power icon one that we started talking about, that one, you see variations of that more than you see any of these.
跨语言和不同尺度下都能工作。尽可能直观和通用。所以如果你去另一个国家开车，看到一个灯亮起，希望你也能知道在那个国家出了什么问题。没错。作为使其通用和易于理解的一部分，IEC 不遗余力地创建这些视觉上相似的符号集或系列。这样一旦你理解了其中一个，你就可以开始猜测其他符号的样子了。是的，我正在翻阅，我认出了很多这些符号，但我们开始谈论的那个电源图标，那个，你看到的变体比你看到的任何这些都要多。
You know, like that it's on every type of gadget and every type of computer or whatever. Yeah, it's super widespread now. And there's this great YouTube video about it on a channel called LGR. The Power Symbol. I imagine most never give it much thought. The narrator chose a bunch of reuses and remixes. And things like company logos, t-shirts, even tattoos for those who are really serious about it. Of all the symbols defined in IEC 60417, the one for power is arguably the one to have best achieved its goal of ubiquity around the world, especially among the tech-loving community.
你知道，它在每种类型的小工具和每种类型的电脑上都有。是的，它现在非常普遍。关于它有一个很棒的 YouTube 视频，在一个叫 LGR 的频道上。电源符号。我想大多数人从来没有多想过它。叙述者选择了一堆重用和混音。还有公司标志、T 恤，甚至对于那些真正认真对待它的人来说，还有纹身。在 IEC 60417 定义的所有符号中，电源符号可以说是最成功地实现了其在全球范围内普及的目标，尤其是在科技爱好者群体中。
So, the symbol really has become recognizable and ubiquitous, which from the perspective of the IEC is great. That means it's working as intended. Can people find the IEC manual online? Oh yeah, they'll be linked on the website to the IEC manual. I'll embed this video that I was just talking about. You can go wild and play guessing games trying to figure out what the different symbols mean.
所以，这个符号确实变得可识别且无处不在，从 IEC 的角度来看，这太棒了。这意味着它正按预期工作。人们可以在网上找到 IEC 手册吗？哦，是的，网站上会有 IEC 手册的链接。我会嵌入我刚才提到的那个视频。你可以尽情发挥，玩猜谜游戏，试图弄清楚不同符号的含义。
Cool. Alright, thanks Kurt. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Emmith Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Kurt Colstead, and Chris Perubey, music by Sean Riel. Katie Mingle is our senior producer. The rest of the team is Delaney Hall, Joe Rosenberg, Sheree Fusef, Avery Trollfument, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown,
酷。好的，谢谢 Kurt。本周的《99% Invisible》由 Emmith Fitzgerald、Vivian Leigh、Kurt Colstead 和 Chris Perubey 制作，音乐由 Sean Riel 提供。Katie Mingle 是我们的高级制作人。团队的其他成员包括 Delaney Hall、Joe Rosenberg、Sheree Fusef、Avery Trollfument、Sophia Klatsker 和我 Roman Mars。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在美丽的市中心 Radio Row 制作，
Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Orc. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. But if you want us to explore the origin of other ubiquitous icons, leave a comment at 99PI.org. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰。《99% Invisible》是 PRX 旗下 Radio Topia 的成员，这是一个极其独立的集体。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上关注我 @RomanMars，关注节目 @99PIorg。我们在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上也有账号。但如果你想让我们探索其他无处不在的图标的起源，请在 99PI.org 上发表评论。PRX 的 Radio Tapio。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。